x is greater than -4.
Don't worry if you struggled a bit with
this one, let me show you how we did it.
So to solve this,
we started with -4x is less than 16.
Just like with a regular linear
equation, we're trying to isolate x.
And we should do this by dividing by -4,
both sides.
And when we do that,
we're left with x is less than -4.
Because 16 divided by -4 is -4.
But this actually isn't quite right.
Let's think about it.
To check our work, we should think of
a number that is actually less than -4.
So for example, -5,
which is less than -4.
If I plug that back into
-4x is less than 16,
I get -4 times -5 is less than 16.
-4 times -5 is +20.
Remember, negative times
a negative is positive.
And so then we get 20 is less than 16,
but that's not a true statement.
20 is actually greater than 16,
not less than 16.
Any time you multiply or
divide both sides of an equality
by a negative number,
you have to flip the inequality sign.
Write this down, it's important.
That's why the solution here is
actually x is greater than -4.